su médico puede recomendarle una terapia
de reemplazo con testosterona si el
nivel de testosterona en su torrente
sanguíneo es significativamente menor
que el normal
la testosterona es una hormona masculina
también llamada andrógenos que se
produce en sus testículos la
testosterona promueve el desarrollo de
características sexuales masculinas y
apoya las funciones masculinas tal como
la producción de esperma y el deseo
sexual
esta hormona es también esencial para el
mantenimiento de la densidad ósea
el nivel de glóbulos rojos la masa
muscular y la sensación de bienestar
los niveles bajos de testosterona en su
sangre pueden resultar en una condición
llamada deficiencia androgénica o
hipogonadismo que puede incluir el
aumento de grasa corporal tamaño
reducido de los músculos y pechos
hinchados si su nivel de testosterona es
bajo puede experimentar un impulso
sexual disminuido disfunción eréctil y
baja cantidad de esperma lo que lleva a
la infertilidad una deficiencia en
testosterona afecta a todas las partes
de su cuerpo incluso puede causar
pérdida del vello corporal aumento de
grasa corporal disminución de masa
muscular disminución de densidad ósea
que puede llevar a osteoporosis anemia
suave pechos hinchados o sensibles
bochornos disminución de energía y
depresión
la terapia de reemplazo con testosterona
es la administración de testosterona
producida por el hombre para elevar el
nivel de esta hormona en su sangre a su
nivel normal y aliviar sus síntomas
puede realizar la terapia con
testosterona con una inyección
parche
o pastillas
si recibe inyecciones recibirá una cada
dos o tres semanas la testosterona se
aplicará en el músculo de sus nalgas
si usa un parche de testosterona para la
piel colocará el parche en su brazo
espalda abdomen o parte superior de sus
nalgas cambiará su parche diariamente si
usa un gel de testosterona lo aplicará
diariamente a la piel en su hombro
antebrazo o abdomen
si usa pastillas bucales colocará una
pastilla en su línea gingival dos veces
al día